did donald trump as president have the
right to unilaterally declassify
documents just based on his say-so
that's one of the conversations we've
been having ever since the fbi raid on
donald trump's home in florida last week
took place and we know that the american
right wing they've been throwing
everything at the wall to see what
sticks as it pertains to the fbi raid in
mar-a-lago saying everything from this
is a witch hunt to the fbi planted
documents on donald trump but one of the
more pernicious claims made in
right-wing media circles lately has been
that even if donald trump did have
classified documents in his possession
in his basement in mar-a-lago that's
a-okay because presidents at the end of
the day are the ultimate authority as to
what is classified information and what
gets declassified so it doesn't matter
it's kind of a get out of jail free card
if the president does it it's not
illegal as richard nixon once said
here's one such example of this claim
being made by cash patel who is a former
trump administration official who now
works over at truth social also known as
troth central he made the claim to fox
news's maria bartoromo over the weekend
on her sunday show let's take a look at
that in october of 2020 he issued a
sweeping declassification order for
every russia gate document in every
single hillary clinton document then on
the way out of the white house he issued
further declassification orders
declassifying whole sets of documents
and this is a key fact that most
americans are missing president trump as
the sitting president is a unilateral
authority for declassification he can
literally stand over a set of documents
and say these are now declassified and
that is done with definitive action
immediately so kash patel here in this
video makes it sound like there's almost
a magic spell involved like donald trump
can just wave his hand over the
documents in question and then poof they
are no longer classified information so
nothing to be seen here nothing to be
investigated well you may be shocked to
learn that this is not actually how the
process works presidents do have the
ability to declassify certain types of
information but there's a procedure
attached to it certain executive branch
officials have the authority to deem
information as confidential secret or
top secret and if it's ultra top secret
then the document will get the sci
designation some of the documents in
donald trump's possession had this very
distinction there are also rules
limiting how the documents can be stored
physically transported or electronically
transmitted when someone with the proper
authority moves to declassify the
documents the executive branch has a
process to involve the other agencies
that might be affected and certainly the
president is one of the people who can
move to make something declassified it's
rarely done but it can happen however
they need to undergo this very same
process and it's not as easy as made
waving a magic wand as cash patel would
have you believe here's former cia
director and former defense secretary
leon panetta who would know a thing or
two about this very topic being even
more frank than i have been about the
process for how to declassify documents
so you're obviously very well versed in
dealing with classified material former
trump aides are now trying to claim that
there was a standing order by the
president donald trump to declassify any
document that left the west wing for
trump's resident
is that how declassification works
even with some of the nation's most
guarded secrets
uh you know that's nonsense and uh and
he knows it
uh the reality is that there is a
process
for declassifying information
uh and presidents want to declassify
they have to follow that process which
basically requires that it be referred
to the agencies that are responsible for
classifying that material they have
something to say as to whether or not
that material should be declassified so
there is
nothing
that i'm aware of
that indicates that a formal step was
taken by this president to in fact
declassify anything right now this is
pretty much bs it's all a bunch of bs
says leon panetta and then there's an
added layer of security when you're
talking about nuclear documents which
donald trump is accused of having in his
possession as documents about nuclear
material are subject to the atomic
energy act which the president does not
have unilateral authority over now
secondary to this entire discussion is
that even if the documents weren't
classified or even if they were deemed
declassified by donald trump right
before he left office with his magic
wand it wouldn't serve to get the former
president out of hot water because none
of the things that donald trump is being
investigated for require the documents
be
classified the espionage act violations
concealing documents and obstruction of
justice are the three things that the
fbi is looking into as it pertains to
donald trump those are not dependent on
whether the information that trump had
in his possession were classified he's
not supposed to be taking hiding or
destroying any of the presidential
records regardless of their
classification status and the government
asked him to return the items he didn't
willingly hand them over he didn't give
back all of the documents anyway and so
it doesn't matter whether or not they
were classified final point on this
because the right has been talking
non-stop about hillary clinton and her
emails over the past couple of weeks
they used to say that hillary clinton
she could not be trusted to handle
secret information therefore she could
not be president because when she was
secretary of state she had uh secret
documents in her gmail account that was
being operated through a private server
and it was grossly negligent we just
can't trust her with these top secret
documents well if that was ever your
concern
but you also now have this position that
the president can just declassify
whatever they want on a whim doesn't
this render the point that they were
making about hillary in 2016 completely
moot like why would it matter that
hillary clinton supposedly uh wasn't
able to be trusted with classified
information if she would have the power
as president to just declassify whatever
she wants anyway but the contradictions
we know when it comes to the right wing
they don't matter it's all about
twisting and turning yourself anything
that you can do to defend donald trump
no matter how ridiculous it makes you
look